mr ambassador a couple of days ago you
said that
claims of an imminent invasion of
ukraine by the russians
are nonsense baseless and paranoid
do you still think that
absolutely
i think recently we have determined the
exact date of uh of our invasion
together with my colleague diplomats
here in new york it is the 30th of
february i think you can mark this date
in your calendar if you find it of
course
if that is the case what is the point of
150 000 troops on the ukrainian border
what are they doing there first of all
uh who counted them uh where do you take
this figure 150 000. i remember it was
100 000 then it was 120 000 now it is
150 000. some people say 190 000. so i
admit inflation is very high here in new
york we see it on the prices but in the
number of soldiers i think it's
inflation demonstrated by satellite
pictures which we have seen and unless
unless the russia is now putting in
cardboard tanks uh there are troops
there well we don't trust the u.s and
british intelligence they let it let us
down the whole world on many occasions
enough to remember
weapons of mass destruction in iraq but
in any case you asked about what are the
troops doing there well they are on our
territory
they are not placed on the border
immediately they are placed in the uh in
the uh in their places where they
usually are on the border would you be
as relaxed if it were the other way
around and ukraine had moved let's say
that the ukrainians had 50 000 troops
and they moved to within a kilometer of
the russian border would you be as
relaxed about it as you are we are not
relaxed and you are very close to the
truth because ukrainians have 120 000 on
the line of contact with donbass and
they started shelling donbass yesterday
that's why of course we we're not
relaxed are you now accusing the
ukrainians of aggression i'm not
accusing them of aggression i am
accusing them of shelling peaceful
population in donbass and this is quite
obvious given it's not about from the
satellites but it's from the people
there from the eyewitnesses i think that
the osce monitoring mission also made
this in the in today's report as far as
as far as i was
informed so this is a fact of life
whether it's aggression or not difficult
to say but when you have 120 000 troops
in full uh in full uh capacity to strike
at the border
the line of contact actually i think you
have to be preoccupied and you have to
think about aggression it's not russian
troops on russian territory all right
well look we can trade numbers but one
thing that we are absolutely certain
about is that mr putin has uh
said
that he is going to conduct
nuclear drills and he will oversee them
himself isn't that a rather dangerous
escalation of the situation which you
yourself have just been describing as a
tense one i don't think that everybody
should tell us when we should or
shouldn't conduct drills our drills
happened before we announced a number of
drills beforehand by the way these were
these in bella russia uh that also went
uh in the center of attention were
announced months ago and they are now
being presented as a kind of russian
alleged escalation this is not true i'm
not i'm not i don't think that our
drills on our territory should should
worry anyone yes but mr putin is a smart
man he must know that in the context
announcing a nuclear drill nuclear drill
isn't going to reduce the tensions is it
well if you have nuclear weapons of
course you need to keep keep keep it in
good shape so drills are necessary from
time to time i'm not responsible for
this the question of course i can't
speak for my president in this regard
i'm sure that he had good reasons to
announce these drills uh there are a lot
of issues i think that the world should
be preoccupied more than our drills on
our territory uh so i'm really very much
not understanding uh what is the what is
the point of being super preoccupied
there some western commentators are
saying that
what is actually happening is that mr
putin didn't anticipate
the western resolve that he would have
to face in the form of nato and european
unity
given the buildup of troops on the
ukraine border has he misjudged the
situation i would say that there are a
lot of things for the world to be
preoccupied
right now
and
you shouldn't judge it in terms of chess
board in terms in terms of geopolitical
struggle i think we made quite clear
that we have absolutely legitimate
concerns
about our security
which is being affected by nato
placement of infrastructure and troops
near our border and we we have the right
to be concerned so we made concrete
proposals these proposals are long
overdue it's not the first time that we
voice our preoccupations i think we did
it for tens of years already we base our
preoccupations on the
uh provisions of basic osce documents of
russian nato act and also on some
promises which
western leaders have given us so this is
quite logical and i think what people
what peace loving people in europe
should be preoccupied is really to stop
the militaristic
tune that is now in the heads of many
many western politicians unfortunately
and to to get to negotiating table and
to see what we can together do in terms
of security for guaranteeing uh russia's
absolutely legitimate concerns well can
i just put lastly another reading of
this situation to you which is this
that
mr putin
is rather enjoying this
that he has western leaders coming to
his table he has a western media talking
about him as we are doing now
and that actually the eyes of the world
are on this situation and indeed the
eyes of the russian people are on this
situation diverting them from russia's
own economic problems i think that
enjoying is not the right word that you
can use in these circumstances when we
see absolutely lack of responsibility
from on behalf of western leaders right
now
and a lot of uh scare monitoring and
warm wandering so i don't know anybody
who is enjoying this situation in russia
and what you said about russia's
economic difficulties well every country
has economic difficulties i assume uk
also has some after the brexit
as well there is a trend
that people say that the problems are
narrowed down to ukraine and to solving
this artificial crisis around ukraine
with alleged russian uh in russian plans
to attack but i want to tell you that
the picture is much bigger and ukraine
is only one piece of this puzzle and
that was exactly we assume i assume
personally that it was exactly the
tactics of our western partners to to
start all this hype when we uh
inform them about our proposal and when
we sent to them draft treaties with u.s
and nato about european security this is
a very strange coincidence isn't it
ambassador thank you very much indeed
for your time this morning thank you